in the 10 years of doing the show in one
version or another we've never said
moniker for a tot Monica
that was words that have never been put
together it's hot moniker would be a
great indie rock Indie Rockman or a
great name for a drink
hey gang ran Dan and Jay here and I want
to talk to you about your pets your dogs
I've got two dogs and if you're like me
you want to make sure you're taking good
care of what you feed your dog that's
right maybe you feed them kibble
recommended by a vet or fresh food diet
but did you know that these are often
low in protein high in carbs and are the
leading cause of weight Mobility dental
and skin conditions that's where Maeve
comes in Maeve raw food diet is
formulated to meet your dog's needs so
here's what you do make the switch to
raw food today right now Maeve is
offering 40 off your first order at meat
m-e-e-t-mave
m-a-e-v.com DPT so go to
m-e-e-t-m-a-e-v.com slash DPT that's
spelled m-a-e-v to receive forty dollars
off your first order that's meetmave.com
guys this show is sponsored by
betterhelp if you're thinking about
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to fit
your schedule so visit betterhelp.com
DPT today to get 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp help help.com DPT boom
hey toddies welcome to another episode
of dumb people account population
is brought to you by the new Mario
Brothers movie I'm joking
wank it's uh it's dumb people Town we're
so happy to have you here
got a brand new special we'll talk about
that later he is I will say this about
Jeremiah Watkins when I see you in
public it makes me happy because I know
goofiness will ensue yeah unless you're
Jeremiah and I and we saw each other uh
what was that about 6 a.m at LAX oh yeah
we were zombies no one was happy it was
very pleasant you're very glad to see
your friend is there landing and you're
taking off
again
I love you but we gotta keep this moving
like both of you both of you became
Shaquille O'Neal
it is where did you come from yeah
[Music]
I should get Shaq on the show
all right uh we got stories yeah here's
the good news the world's getting Dumber
even though you have a beautiful smart
special coming out the world is getting
Dumber in the midst of all that we're
gonna jump into a story I got the first
story I love doing this is sent in by
Beck s at Doctor BX doctor
here's the headline okay mom so we know
it's from England mom uh-huh mum named
baby girl after the lockdown and says
she has no regrets she doesn't name her
post lockdown you mean she she's named
in regards to yeah she names the babies
your great uncle your favorite great
uncle she named it after the lockdown
okay can we guess well that's one of the
guesses stay at home
work from home yeah shelter shelter
shelter Shelly Shelley shelter
[Laughter]
uh this is my son n95.
kind of a cool name uh baby girl
actually yeah by the way that could have
been an Elon musk's kid right
oh yeah and then it would be n95 here
woman here's what I want to know she
says she has no regrets
no regrets have crossed the board I have
regrets every day anybody who has no
regrets
is constantly doing things wrong like
they're just on the wave and they can't
look back also they're wearing an Ed
Hardy shirt for yeah thank you did you
know that stuff's coming back coming way
back it is so back my daughter has two
pieces of dirty stuff and I was like
she's like it's you guys she's like it's
it's retro it's I grabbed a cocktail at
Birds on Franklin right everybody's uh
UCB Hank unless you're sure unless
you've got a TV show then you're down at
La pu Belle okay and um I look over and
unironically well I guess I'll totally
22 23 year old woman wearing a Von Dutch
hat oh oh wow so that's part of it
that's coming back and I've done a lot
of dumb fashion stuff in my life
thanks buddy I want to be consistent
I've never done any doesn't this look
good because it's bad like uh like that
to me I'm ironic yes I never did the
thing where it's like because it's so
bad it's good cool that it looks stupid
and I've done
I met my wife while wearing a wallet
chain so the fact that I'm still married
you didn't do that thinking isn't it
funny I'm weird like it's kind of like
someone's gonna steal my wallet I better
lock this [__] down yeah the 14 in there
no one can have access to that so what
if she named her baby Ed Hardy let's
just keep uh well that wouldn't let me
get into it related uh this down lock it
down mom Ed Hardy's take on the pandemic
I'm sure just went to Hermosa every day
yeah at her is like is that a person is
that so it's not an actual person is it
I want it to be someone Google why
wouldn't it I don't think it's a real
thing let them tell us all right let's
lay our bets Ed Hardy really quick Aaron
tell us there's no way he's real no ways
100 real Jay I think it's not real I
don't think there's an Edward Hardy out
there he's like Aaron will look it up
okay but I want if there is it not real
Jeremiah on this side of the fence is
not real if there isn't Ed Hardy I want
him to have have a son who's 14 and a
son who's 16 I want them to be called
The Hardy Boys
growing up dude did they revamp Hardy
Boys but with like sleeves and stuff
that's gonna happen dude
why are we doing that schedule we gotta
get Chad and JT and have them become the
Edwards
they would crush that wouldn't they all
right here we go okay uh a mom who named
her baby after the pandemic says she has
no regrets and doesn't care what anyone
thinks good Jody cross I'm not going to
tell you how old she is she's the same
age as her dumb husband okay fell
pregnant with her first daughter now I'm
pregnant that's you fall ill you don't
fall on his penis and then yeah then
they have a baby so that means unplanned
right okay I'm sorry I fell pregnant he
didn't want a baby I don't know I think
I'm coming down with something I think
it's a baby so we're gonna name it we're
gonna name it Biden's virus
we called it the China virus we called
it the Wuhan Choo Chan uh she's pregnant
with her first daughter during the
second coronavirus lockdown in 2021 a
year after trying to start a family some
people get a puppy so it didn't fail you
felt you wanted that for a year fell
pregnant Jody and her husband Rob do we
want to guess how old they are now
because that's the name of the baby at
the end how old do you think these
dummies married wanted a child yeah I'm
gonna go 34 years old Dan says third
year of Walter Payton Jeremiah how old
is this couple yeah they're the same age
yeah they're the same age oh I think
that they're 22. 22 years old yeah I say
31. okay all right get your answers in
shout at your ham radios because Rob and
Jody cross are both 36 years old wow
Daniel okay Dan was on the right track
two years off so at 36 how old are you
sir 34. 34. yeah that's the Walters
Dan's in the range of 32 42 but I always
think of you as perpetually 35 36. so
you guys are close to that age yeah that
feels like an age that you would know
better than to name okay they have a kid
and name it after like having like to me
they treated this kid like it was a
tattoo they're like this is a good thing
to name it in the moment they opted for
a unique moniker for their Tot To
Remember the coronavirus lockdown like
they were gonna forget it in the 10
years of doing the show in one version
or another we've never said moniker for
a tot Monica
that was words that have never been put
together it's hot moniker would be a
great indie rock indie rock man or a
great name for a drink yeah I have two
or a bra or like a TLC show top monsters
I'll have two top monikers you want them
on Ice sure yeah they're little they're
little drinks yeah I'll take two dot
monikers neat uh that is yeah Dan that's
a great call but to remember the corona
is that why we all have trouble
remembering it Jeremiah that is my
question no I'm I'm not gonna have any
issues I don't think we people are going
to continue to bring it up forever
like the pandemic people are going to
want to forget this child I had the
Neighbors in Chicago who named their
child after the bar they met at and
luckily they met at Collins on South
Portland that's a cool name great name
but that that's a slippery slope
shortstop desserts on Dave Buster
Dave
David's middle name
this is Chili's he loves the game this
is Chili's too Cheesecake Factory get
over here
steakhouse
steakhouse steakhouse
hairdresser Jody credited the
coronavirus lockdowns being the reason
they finally were able to get pregnant
because they had more time to try for a
baby due to being on furlough okay
they're these two were that busy yeah
can't have sex no just two I got too
much to do it takes like about two
minutes honestly and you have a window
or I mean if you're trying it's like hey
hey today tomorrow I'm ovulating get in
here and let's do this right now Jody
said the lockdown was a quote really
good time
I don't know if you bragged that when
like do you say when you're you know
when you're getting knocked up and yeah
finally finally had a chance to do that
it was a good time in their lives most
people clean out their garage yeah and I
guess that's a euphemism
[Applause]
it was a one-car garage he turned into
it whoa uh the mom of one said double
parking uh although it might be a
surprise she has no regrets over the
name Choice Jody from bedfordshire said
we've been trying for a year to get
pregnant and locked on men I was
furloughed and Rob was working less so I
put him to work a little bit
I think we just relaxed a bit we had so
much more time than we normally would
and then we found out I was pregnant
preggers when she was born the new
strain of kova was coming out uh so we
knew we're going Omicron well you'll
guess at the end okay okay so the name
Crown is like an Omarosa yeah kind of
it's also a Transformer yeah 100 so the
baby will transform into a crop
we'll be a small truck
it's a mask so this is her people might
not like the name but I don't care what
they think
yeah yeah she's trying to get in front
of the fact that people don't care Jody
told how she and Rob were in the same
class at school but lost contact until
meeting again on Tinder on November
2019. they met again on tonight they
were in the same class they quickly
struck up a conversation
on Tinder is the goal on Tinder is to
find someone who don't worry
you've never done Tinder I've never done
Tinder none of us okay here we go is Ed
Hardy on Tinder uh look it up so wait
but am I wrong well you could search on
a radius so they probably both so lived
in the same town and they're like oh my
God I remember him from my school we
used to date and then it probably came
up they swiped on each other they
matched and then it went off from there
but that but my question is wouldn't you
on Tinder want to find someone who knows
nothing about you because it's just like
that it's more about your probability of
having having sex with that person sure
oh so he's like okay this is someone who
knows who I am so there's a little
familiar familiar he's Off to the Races
right I think like two steps ahead okay
and if they hadn't seen each other I'm
sure that one or obviously both of them
were like oh my God they look good yeah
swipe they might crush on each other
yeah a little history yeah this is how
this is Tinder romance it's Ed Hardy
alive man yeah we do not find out I want
people to tell us YouTube comments
after live shows right double for the
rest of our careers
that's how we start all of our live
shows in moon tower we're like dumb
people town
a real Dan we gotta do that uh romance
quickly Blossom between the students
they started dating until coronavirus
struck and the country hit a standstill
in March 2020. thank you article for
telling us this information yeah exactly
and the Nationwide lockdown in the UK
began Jody explained at the time that at
the time she and Rob are living
separately so Rob who has one child from
a previous relationship moved into her
flat with her okay right nesting
together they began trying to have a
baby no luck for a year it was only when
they began assuming it wasn't going to
happen that they got a surprise this is
normal this is
probably not gonna happen you didn't
think you'd meet someone that you
already knew which is not meeting
someone right I made a human I ended up
taking over a little Salon during
lockdown because I had been on okay we
don't need to hear it this is so much
information so about these people uh the
couple were overjoyed and even surprised
their families by getting married in
secret when Jody was how many months
pregnant did they get married yeah three
I'm gonna say six
five
get your answers in one of you is one
month off four
two
seven
Jeremiah is right
now I'm just ready to ride ready she'd
be showing yeah she'd be showing hard
it's not a baby
uh in November their first child
together was born the couple opt to name
her and we will get the name at the end
uh Jody said the unusual Choice
represented the happy time for them and
she and Rob had the best time throughout
the pandemic why didn't everyone have
the best time oh yeah these people are
talking about people were dying we know
lots of people didn't enjoy the lockdown
but for us it was a good time you know
we lost in our you know how some people
lose their sense of their taste and
smell these people lost their
self-awareness right yeah there's a way
to say like I know the lockdown was
rough on a lot of people because people
died we did our part to bring life into
this world no this is Instead This is
what she said we actually had the best
time in lockdown with both of us being
home we had no worries and found it
really relaxing okay
hahaha
the toll Rising yeah
we named her after a good time not a bad
one uh although some people might find
her uh mad for choosing to name her
daughter based on such a hard time by
the way also for other people screw you
this is what the baby's named and you
can figure something out it's like this
is hurting it can't wait till we find
out I know
uh she said Not only was the name based
on lockdown but several coincidences
leading up to her birth where the word
kept appearing again and again I as we
close out Story number one I will ask
you all what do you think she named this
child I'm gonna go with efficacy
uh no give us give us what you think I'm
gonna go with Kung Fu
that's terrible terrible
Learners
I'm gonna go with Omicron I like when
you said that that's probably the call
oh official
I think it's just gonna be as simple as
Corona yeah so there's a good call so I
just had to say Delta there's a woman
whose kids went to school with my kids
and she is Israeli and her name is imbal
great name ever and greatest name and
she will she had a big white fluffy dog
named Delta that would never do what she
wanted Delta to do so the entire time
you're ever around her with the dog you
start having a conversation in an
Israeli accident Delta
so if this is Delta that's what I'm
doing that's your name in ball in ball
no my daughter is in class with someone
with the greatest name he's Mongolian
and his name is
you say Corona straight up
straightforward
yeah this name is somehow less creative
and less good than all of us are you
ready as we end Story number one Dan
it's almost as big a2n2 no they named
their daughter
way to go you gave this kid the worst
life ever blocky is this spelled
l-o-c-k-i-e walking not Loki
straight out of the Marvel Universe no
he would have been great lucky and it's
a name that like as you start to dig
into it this kid is just gonna forever
have to be like my parents are Amy after
the corona 50 years would be better lock
lock yeah lock would be a better lck or
l-o-c-k-e yeah or hello
q-u-e or yeah
all right there you go there you go
that's it I'm sorry I'm sorry your 36
year old parents are uh are idiots all
right no regrets Story one down in the
books when we come back we'll find out
Jeremiah's got a new stand-up special we
uh have our guests set for uh the DPT
Moon I will tell you all about that all
the good stuff on the other side
and we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
thankfully it is therapy uh I understand
the world of therapy it means a lot to
me my wife is a therapist and I
understand the importance of it we know
how it fits in people's lives you can
tell your friends a bunch of things but
you can only tell a therapist your
deepest thing and they will be there to
listen to you and to reflect what's
going on what makes better help so great
yeah it's all about getting to know
yourself and getting to know yourself
can be a lifelong process especially
because we're always growing and we're
always changing I mean this whole the
last couple of years in the pandemic
I've changed since that whole thing the
world has changed it better help
connects you with a licensed therapist
who can take you on that journey of self
self-discovery from wherever you are so
I mean I've done it I've done therapy
I've gone through better hope it's very
simple very easy some of the things I
love about it too
um it's entirely online as I said it's
designed to be convenient flexible
suited to your schedule you just fill
out the brief questionnaire that I
mentioned and you get matched with a
licensed therapist and here's what I
also like too because this is really
important a lot of people think therapy
you go oh that's your person no
sometimes you need to find a person
that's right for you right and they make
it so easy to switch your therapist
anytime for no additional charge I love
it so much discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com DPT
today to get 10 off your first month Jay
that is better help
h-e-l-p.com slash d p t
ran yeah you have two dogs that you love
I love Roman my old one and Ponyo my
little girl you do have a you have a new
and an old you have a used and a lease
but the least you're going to own this
one uh we have a brand new Advertiser
I'm so happy that Maeve is our
advertisers because for years I've been
feeding my dog kibble and both of the
dogs and I didn't realize that before
you try to buy other stuff and you think
it's it's good and healthy and it turns
out it's not so I didn't realize like
the benefits of a great diet like a
Maeve diet I'm gonna read some off good
health gut health immune function oral
hygiene skin and code Health hip and
joint health important for your dog
mental health and anxiety growth and
early development dogs are like people
they don't need processed food right you
want something that is high in protein
lower in carbs and that's where the raw
food of made comes in it comes Frozen
and it's in little pieces that actually
help your dog so it's a serve it to them
first yeah yeah you do you do give that
to the dog you give it to the dog but it
actually helps them clean their teeth so
I was buying other things to help clean
the teeth but this can help clean your
dog I love that there's no mess no prep
no thawing just open pour and serve it
is that easy who else can say they get
all their favorite foods every single
day I mean other than me at like a Vegas
buffet but how often do you get that how
often do you take your dog to a Vegas
but by the way Dan you're not you're not
eating as well as my dogs now my dogs
are eating mafes so they're eating
better than you um people love me if
they have over 1 000 five-star reviews
and so do their dogs especially those
notorious picky eaters yeah Jay tell
them what to do right okay make the
switch to rotten today right now Maeve
is offering forty dollars off your first
order at meetmave.com DPT go to
meetmave.com DPT that's spelled
m-e-e-t-m-a-e-v to receive forty dollars
off your first order I'm telling you my
dogs love this food it also looks good
it looks really good they love this food
they're acting better they're feeling
better meet Maeve
m-e-t-m-a-e-v.com slash DPT for forty
dollars off this amazing food for your
dogs
now back to the show um
hey guys welcome back to the show uh we
got some stuff to talk about we're going
to talk about Jeremiah's special but
first let's get out uh what we have
going on we're going to announce our
guest for uh the dumb people town that
we're doing live at moon tower which I'm
so excited and I don't know if you can
announce the living wake can you
announce that okay good we'll do all
that right here right now uh so next
month we'll be at moon tower the third
weekend in April in Austin Texas if
you're there it's like one of the best
you know you love that Festival my
favorite best ever it's like pure comedy
for Pure comedy lovers Joy so we're
doing a live down people town and our
two guests are Natalie palomides and
Dolce Sloan I love both of them we
haven't had either of them on the
podcast like Natalie's uh her special on
Netflix I think I think about that
special a lot it feels like something
like you would do I don't know if you
saw her special but it was amazing but
like performer incredible performer and
don't say it's someone we've wanted to
have on for a long time and just we
she's a New York person and we never
really have her out here so just excited
so that's happening and then we're doing
tag it with some amazing people
Natalie's going to do tag it Dana Gould
is doing it Adam Ray is doing it uh
Andrew just music Andrew dismukes is
doing it it's gonna be an ins uh Lisa
and Walters is doing it Lisa traeger's
doing it and we might get an
international person to do it as well so
we're doing both of those and this comes
out this show comes out next uh Tuesday
this coming Tuesday from when we're
recording it next weekend we're going to
be in Phoenix Arizona that's right at uh
stand up live I love that club so much
we want to try and sell out some of
these shows it's a huge Club look we got
your April Fool's Day plans you want to
go see comedy on April Fool's Day
Saturday night Saturday night April
fools 4-1 we'll see you at Phoenix's
stand-up live two shows and we got two
shows on Friday around the 31st and then
two on 30. and you can see all of our
dates and whatnot superscars.com will be
Minneapolis in May Daniel you know what
I'll do mine before the third story
because I want to get to his special all
right let's do it all right so let's
talk about your special my man let's
talk about it it's out now it's called
Jeremiah Watkins Daddy yeah yeah Daddy
Daddy shot it at uh Madison Wisconsin
for you uh no
I would love to get Gus on stage with me
sometime yeah he's the greatest I know
it is just comedy Heaven There and
everyone's so smart they just have done
like the most beautiful job with that
club yeah then make you feel welcome and
warm there and yeah did you shoot it
over a couple of nights or over one
night
and I I most of the show I want to say
uh the whole I got it all except about
four minutes from uh one other show but
for the most part it's all one show was
it the first or the second the early
show the early yeah so that's crazy it's
a high wire act I mean it's almost like
you wanna that's so great that you feel
like because your emotion is high you
want to deliver you know you're
recording and when you got off stage
you're like oh my God that was
phenomenal I'm like I think I I think
that was the one and I was like oh we
got another one for safety so yeah
amazing exactly right dude uh and where
can people get it how can people
consider free on YouTube just type in
Jeremiah Watkins daddy or Jeremiah
Watkins stand end up it'll come right up
okay so this is your requirement your
requirement is to enjoy yourself and
watch Jeremiah yeah share it uh send the
link to people let's help if you've
never seen his stand up it is so Jay and
I love the act out you know I would say
if I would describe Dan as like a
phenomenal phenomenal wreck Contour his
storytelling ability is second to none
you see how he does it and how he's sort
of it's also amazing at characters but
his stand-up is more storytelling so we
do a lot less about Jeremiah more about
me okay more about you we do a lot of
stuff where it's almost like sketch and
stand up where we present a premise and
then act it out his act outs are like
you're like a human cartoon and so I
feel like some of the best act outs of
premises ever you lay out the premise so
economically and so good and then boom
and get to the fun man
physical stuff it's so physical it's so
fun the energy is so great you will
you'll thank us when you watch and it's
out right now it's out now and maybe
leave something like a dumb people Town
common so I know that you came from yeah
the podcast heard you on dumb people
Town watch your special absolutely loved
it yeah comments you're getting people
Town yeah Daddy people down yeah good
ratings and give it a highest rating and
and tell other people about it thumbs up
a thumbs up thumbs up and let's get
everybody let's get everybody watching
this message all right let's do Story
number two and then before Story number
three Dan's got two wonderful
announcements okay you guys ready for
this yeah let's do it let's do it send
him by Carlene McDermott
Carlene one of our great sender zinners
headline is this this comes from UK news
we're over there we're in England in the
UK sorry state
of rare Mercedes after car wash worker
took it for a joyride this is the Ferris
Bueller's Day Off it is your fear when
you when you go to valet park a car when
you leave your fear
I think it lives in the back of
everyone's mind the second you hand your
keys to anyone and they drive your car
away there is a chance that they could
just drive forever do you know Rove
Mcmanus the comedian do you know he's
he's from damn it Dan and no
um yeah I was listening to just a little
thing of his and he did he he talked
about a great thing about selfies and
how like selfies has taken away the
ability for you to hand your camera over
to someone else yeah and that that brief
interaction of like can you take a
picture of me we kind of do it in line
when we're at the merch lines where
we're like can you take a picture of
them and then you get people talking and
it's like kind of a beautiful moment in
that one thing it forces you to interact
with people and he's like and also
there's this chance where you're like
there's a second where like they could
run off with my camera oh yeah you know
what I mean like there's that second so
we're playing in that right here that
you give the keys and you're like
there's a chance what do you think it's
familiar with the service avail
no car service it's over by LAX you
could park your car uh it's free they
it's free if they accept your car if
they accept your car it's free they
detail your car for you and then while
you are traveling they rent your car out
and you split the profits what what and
they're very extremely particular about
the cars that they accept so they're not
taking on a CRZ 2012. right they might
but uh
CRZ so you then split the profit with
them if they rent out your car and if
they don't then it's just free uh if
they don't it might I think it's an i
they won't accept it if they're if they
don't think they can can we get more in
the Weeds on this thing yeah yeah
so what's the number if you're driving
yeah just tell me the number I don't
know if you guys knew about it anyway
what street are they on Dan what street
are they on I have no idea and other
people's Century what's their customer
service like is it good I've just heard
about it I don't have a nice enough car
you should do it let's get in the Weeds
about it um you don't want to be in the
weeds I want to be in the car out well
then I won't tell you guys about air
tags and if you should put an air tag in
your car I love air tags do you use them
do you use them
I've been recommended tiles
way better why the radius on it it pings
off of iPhones you'll know wherever your
things are at all times put one in your
car put one in your luggage for sure
that one in your life put one inside
this story about are we not responsible
a car wash worker
see it feels like two years did you um
three and a half years in Kansas maybe
wow you were spraying what were you
doing just operating you're taping the
back of people's uh
automated like they went through you
drove it on to uh
breaks move over I literally did
everything I vacuumed I cleaned my wife
just dig the pit I mean you know dig the
pit are we bearing bodies what do you
mean so there's a pit that goes
underneath the car wash that is
basically the sewage system for
everything that falls off the car
disgusting what are you doing what are
you doing today Jeremiah dig in the bed
digging the pit it's like ditch digging
that was that was uh if you messed up
over and over that was punishment that
they would make you dig the pit and try
to love someone yeah
okay thank you Jason the car wash worker
crashed a customer's classic there's way
too many C's saw this too happen by the
way continue the car wash worker crashed
a customer's classic Mercedes-Benz oh
yeah during an illicit Joyride after he
swerved to avoid a mouse
[Laughter]
that might be a [__] thief that loves
animals yeah I respect that dude this is
is that Stuart Little
down here I can't hear him he's a
talking Mouse look at him he's in the
best he's in a wife's coat it's the
cutest little mouse I've ever seen
[__] wait that's true of deny had to
Swerve a little bit didn't I yeah Didn't
I it isn't it a boss caused
[Laughter]
caused so much damage to the rare 1992
550e vehicle after he lost control while
trying to avoid the rodent as it
scampered across the road just drive the
mouse will know what to do stay put
Kevin Murphy returned to pick up his
Mercedes one of only 29 models imported
to the UK only to find it had
written off in the smash now wow yes now
what does that mean that was totaled it
was total yes
yeah yeah you guys want to guess how
much they're worth in America in 1992.
this is the best I could find only 29
were made no imported to the UK only 29
imported to the UK so your guess I
couldn't find out what that would make
it worth in the area okay yeah yeah this
is like anything but over here it's more
common I guess maybe so at the very
minimum do you want to guess the worth
of this in 1990
USD 30 of them you said yeah 29 models
were imported to the to the UK but I
could only find the worth here in the
U.S which is I will tell you probably
way less because we have plenty of them
so we're gonna guess the worth of that
yeah I'm gonna guess well in the US or
the UK here you here here I think it's
probably 1980 000 car okay
okay 120 000. okay uh sixty thousand you
guys are nice they're only worth about
13k here what but maybe a scarcity
causes oh yeah right on Ft pricing if
it's only 29 that thing is probably
worth a lot of money in the UK inquiries
revealed that iranian-born uh Abbas I
don't know why that's relevant who has
not passed his UK driving test but got a
job I love that they had to needle this
guy you're not oh is that the wait a
minute is a boss the worker okay so he's
working at the car wash
thank you had earlier taken the car for
a spin from his workplace in runcorn
Cheshire washer to his home in Stockport
Stockport greater Manchester and then
back again he crashed just five miles
away from dropping the car back just
five miles I've always crashed five
miles from your house five miles back
how far how many miles do you think he
put on this
you wouldn't know but from runcorn to
Stockport oh you talk about the Run
point of Scott Port yeah yeah there's a
Burt Reynolds movie about that run porn
run Jason how many miles
he should not be driving with a license
he does not have I think he drove 30
miles okay Randy uh I think he drove 120
miles okay yeah I was going to say at
least 90 miles he drove 60 miles
a boss was found lying beside the
vehicle and was treated in an ambulance
next to he wasn't hurt lying he laid
down to make it look worse yeah yeah
this is England where the English
Premier League like if someone almost
trips you you go down and you clutch I'm
like anytime I see someone laying by a
car who wasn't there my first thing is
like did the Murdoch's dude what
happened here
in a statement Mr Murphy said the car
which has about 26 000 miles on the
clock was usually chauffeur driven so
this would be way wow
it was a cherished and prized possession
I was incredibly upset yeah of course
you were a British way of putting it
while I do not feel vulnerable or
intimidated as a result of this okay no
one asked you if you felt intimidated no
this is not an active interview this is
someone recklessly taking your car no
one's trying to intimidate you
bother but you did steal my car I'm
feeling very intimidated but and yet I'm
not vulnerable about it uh I am now
incredibly cautious about who I trust my
vehicles with okay
at Warrington magistrates Court Abbas
pleaded guilty to aggravated vehicle
taking and driving without a license or
insurance and was banned from driving
for 12 months Grant aggravated granted
permission
aggravated vehicle taking feels like a
six-year-old came up with that yeah what
is it it's or like somebody
aggravated vehicle what'd he do he took
the vehicle to taking uh the cat it's
like your dad trying to like yeah a
separate charge of driving without due
care and attention was withdrawn despite
the smash Abbas and the victim are still
said to be on good terms how because
they're British and it's very like
gonna hold it again you have a freaking
chauffeur you call a service over to
your house and you have them wash it in
your driveway new character Angela
Blackmore Prosecuting said during she
got robbed at the Oscars during
interview the defendant said the vehicle
had been dropped off to the car wash and
he drove it to Stockport and back he
only had a provisional driver's license
in relation to the crash she stated a
mouse ran onto the road and he swerved
to avoid it there's nothing more
interesting if you give a mouse a crash
in mitigating for a boss who had no
previous convictions right Philip green
Lee said he shows a lot of remorse and
this appears to be genuine remorse he is
not employed at the same car wash but he
was offered his job back they want him
back dude he's decided not to accept the
offer of employment so this is a boss
going you know what I don't want to work
for you anymore yeah I'm quoting Selene
McCullough's bit and I'll do it all the
time because it's the greatest bit he's
like you cannot get fired at McDonald's
he's like I stab your manager stab your
manager good man I still need you guys
yeah they need you you cut me deep a
boss was handed a 12-week suspended
sentence he'd never had one right uh and
was ordered to complete 150 hours we're
gonna understand the license you don't
have Dan right I know he was paid uh 200
oh and to pay 213 pounds in costs and
victim surcharge no order for
compensation was made we'll get out of
here and wait
he's paying for it insurance
just done well it depends if he has a
classic car insurance then it's valued
at whatever he says it's worth that's
right the expensive jewelry or something
like that but if he had just straight up
auto insurance they are just going to
assess it at whatever a 1992 car in the
United States yeah and they'd probably
be like this is worth thirteen thousand
dollars we'll pay for yeah oh my God oh
my God I love that they're still friends
I would be so mad get out of here on
this how old is Omid Abbas now what do
we know about him is loves mice doesn't
care about your car needed to get home
in the middle of the day I heard a mouse
doesn't want his job back at the car
wash and is somehow on good terms with
the man who's right he's like I don't
need this stupid Car Wash I can't wait
to show them to you guys after that I
guess I think he's got to be 40. okay I
think he's 23. okay 31. well one of you
is one year off so give me some ups and
downs 24. okay 41 32.
one of you nailed it because Omid Abbas
is
41 years
[Applause]
this guy should know better yeah he's
got like the kind of glasses that mean
you don't steal a car okay you can tell
he's a laugher too by looking Dan this
is a guy I would go to and be like
should we steal this car and you know
what his response 99. no his response
says don't do it yeah you're gonna get
that's not the guy who steals the car
gives you sensible advice
I know I know what it is you don't even
have to pass it to this guy this is
about a guy who was bored okay and then
does one of the most dangerous things
ever because he's bored that's happening
in Story number three Jeremiah Watkins
is with us Dad after this break it's
dumb people tell we having fun we'll be
right back
hey guys welcome back to the show before
I take us home Daniel Van Kirk in
announce announce away I will tell you
that uh April 14th is the next would you
rather comedy show in Houston Texas uh
great stand-up sets and Comics get asked
would you rather questions that they've
never heard before there's also a chance
we'll be bringing the show on a monthly
basis to La that's the secret group go
to secret group htx.com or Daniel of
anchor.com and then obviously I'm going
to be at Moontower I'll be doing
stand-up sets and uh we'll be doing and
then I'll be doing we're doing the
living wake of Big Jay oakerson yes yes
awesome yeah so he's going to be on this
uh podcast coming up because he's in La
we're going to record that with him next
week and maybe we'll drop that right
before yes to get people excited and
then Irene two and I we have our show
coming back it is at the cats crawl it
starts on April 24th so the day after I
get back from moon tower it is Irina and
I hosting just a great stand-up showcase
show obviously we'd love to have all of
you on it I love it and by every all of
you I mean everyone listening to this
that's right yeah send in another
submission
um you can go to danielvanger.com Once
those things are up and uh
shall we jump in every other Monday okay
here we go this next story is brought in
sent in by Joseph agacioni
at ancient whiz dumb dumb which is
perfect it was sent in on 11-2
22 and this is the headline okay man
planted world's most dangerous plant
because he was born
this is what too much time in my hands
Tommy Shaw said it was the most
dangerous plant I don't know it's called
marijuana
that's the devil that's right Devil's
Lettuce grown out of the ground right
there right although I do have a friend
who he was a name and he does use
affirmative
but outside of that it's I know another
person had ripped apart their life from
the family front side inside out caucus
of marijuana all because of the devil's
lettuce yeah wow it's got to be poison
right a little a little boredom can be
dangerous especially if it I mean this
one I mean Idle Hands right
like ABC news
said Idle Hands of the Devil's
Playground no it's Idle Hands is the
devil's workshop well one why would it
be where one is the devil's Legacy
don't give me the guy who's like so in
he's obviously very into marijuana but
has to posture because he thinks it's
definitely bad yeah that's right I mean
I heard there's people with bongs out
there
he took something like nine milligrams
ripped his own eyes out ripped them out
lettuce is the marijuana's devil it
makes you think you can fly
a little boredom can be dangerous
Devil's hands can't be dangerous
especially if it pushes you to grow one
of the quote world's deadliest weeds I
love it went from a plant in the
headlines
there's also a show on TLC world's
deadly sweets also you were right weed
native to Australia and Malaysia well
already in Australia you have to assume
it's everything will kill you this is
the funniest name ever and I'm like I
can't believe this is the name Dr
ravioli no I'm talking about the gimpy
gimpy
g-y-m-p-i-e-g-i-g-y-m-p-i-e the gimpy or
guy oh that's the name of the plant yeah
oh the little gimpy gimpio
right uh the gimpy gimpy can deliver a
sting so painful it can cause Suicidal
Thoughts would deliver it's not like
well it's not coming at you it's not
jetting it'll deliver it a sting wait
what does it do to you it can provide it
can cause Suicidal Thoughts like a bell
and Sebastian song oh my gosh
Daniel Daniel and Daniel Daniel Daniel
emelyn Jones Emeline Dash Jones so he's
got a hyphenated last name I love it
e-m-l-y-n Jones this dude's scary from
Oxford yeah I'll show you a picture this
is this is what he looks like oh that's
bored he definitely looks like he is
trying to cultivate the look of the
Stephen what's his name from The
Barenaked Ladies Circa 1994. I pull that
reference yes Stephen
Stephen something anyway I thought you
were going to Steven Avery first Stephen
A Smith uhuri's father for Daniel
Emeline Jones from Oxford this was not a
worry as he wanted to say he looks like
a burner account right
you know the egg that used to be like
the symbol on like yeah
glasses based on his face Daniel emelyn
Jones from Oxford uh for him this was
not a worry as he wanted to add quote a
bit of drama
to his gardening who's gardening and
being like you know what this is just I
like the gardening but if there's not
enough drama I can't be doing it come on
let's get some TNT actually it's TNT
knows gardening okay instead of planting
orchids or a fiddly fig tree weird uh
dubbed some of the hardest to nurture
the and we're not going to get his age
yet you saw a picture of him but it can
be misleading opted for the member of
the nettle family so I'm just guessing
oh okay the nettle family you know who
was one of the most poisonous Nettles
ever Jennifer Nettles of uh Craig
Nettles so great on righteous gemstones
right oh my God he said Craig Nettles is
on righteous gemstone no Jennifer folks
he said quote I thought it would just
add a bit of drama to my gardening you
can get seeds on the internet you have
to be careful it doesn't spread out of a
contained area though so I keep it
potted in my front room tell me you live
alone without telling me tell me met a
woman in your house there are no kids in
your house there's no one saying we're
not even having that you don't even have
a dog yeah I'm thinking of buying a
poisonous your partner's like nope right
yeah okay okay it's called a suicide
plan hear me out here we go all right
who wants to do you want to come home
and see my Suicide plan no some women
would no no dog no kidding Mike I love
that you said you might have a snake
honey the kevorkians are blooming they
look great I said this is what I wrote
down your front room or as we like to
call it a room that no woman will ever
see all right front room I got my seeds
from a company in Australia it cost
we're gonna come up with that too how
much money I'm guessing expensive okay
uh so it wasn't cheap I'll say that I've
always liked plants though I uh just
have I just have got a bit bored with
geraniums so this is it he's bored yeah
yeah he's moving this to me is how every
James Bond villain starts with geraniums
you start planning the suicide plant and
then you'll take over the world and then
you're flipping around
this is what the plant looks like pretty
green is that it looks pretty innocuous
I know but it's got like weird does it
have thorns how does it deliver it can
deliver this thing if you touch the
sides I believe oh like kind of the see
how it's like kind of oh it has okay we
did a patriot we did a patreon episode
recently I it's either just come out or
it's about to also plug for our patreon
did you guys know you can like you send
in your dumb stories and then where am I
yeah and we will we will read them so we
just did one of somebody who was playing
ultimate frisbee in college right kind
of all you need to know about them yeah
and they to make it a catch they were
running towards a cactus garden oh my
God and it would have like a cement
barrier around it they thought they
could like jump onto the barrier and
then jump and push themselves back off
they misjudged that obviously because
this is a dumb people Town story
and then they were faced with do I just
my hands hands down and ruin my palms or
just let myself legs like fall into it
this is somebody who was like doing
activities around plants that could hurt
you why would you willingly bring this
into your life also like because they
like Jumanji that's right yeah
I'm back on board
so but like you know how you are in your
house there's times you're coming in
with groceries and stuff and you knock
into it it's in his front room it's
probably by the front door yes my
Suicide plant by the front door don't
get out of my own car last night Dan I
was not drinking no what that's just I
had to get it was an awkward I had to
come from the side to reach into the far
back and I came I knew I had a bad angle
on it and I just I touched myself into
the door frame oh God Son of a bill
Jesus God damn it son of a [__]
all right so let's first do how much
money the seeds cost in Australian
dollars I don't know the the conversion
I don't mean either but just take a
guess and Australian dollars
approximately how much a thousand Aus
okay I think they call it feathers
I'm gonna
[__] I don't know 80 80 feathers 80 okay
Jay what do you think uh hold on you're
trying to do the conversion right now
I'm trying to do it okay uh so an
Australian dollar equals I wanted you so
badly to go uh Ed Hardy Israel
I cannot find out we can't cannot find
out uh 67 cents 67 cents no to the
dollar he said they're expensive oh to
the dollar to the US dollar so you said
how many I said a thousand Aus
yeah I said 80 feathers or 80 bucks 80
bucks so he's talking about 100 like 50
bucks all right I'm gonna say this one
the other way I'm gonna say
500 Australian dollars okay get your
answers in shout them at your ham radios
gang because these crazy seeds for
plants that are suicidal plants cost
something like 60 Australian dollars
damn you're wrong
Dan does this feel like that potato chip
that's like hotter than hell anyway have
you done that it comes in one bag hot
chip challenge yeah you did multiple
times oh my God if we like hot stuff I
do I've I've eaten so many crazy hot you
gotta go on hot ones I would love to I
think we all would love to we'll soon I
would love to wait yeah call up Sean
Evans I know he's my Illinois guy and
you're like come on do it let's do it
for the champagne Urbana please we can
do it on the patreon if you want to take
the hot chip challenge I absolutely I'll
say this if you guys want to do the hot
chip challenge I will join you on your
patreon to do it oh see oh [__] I could
not even take I would watch Daniel I
would watch you guys do it oh you have
to
two hours before it's gone what the
feeling the the oh well if you decide to
it well it's a metric system so if you
last 10 minutes you get like kind of
like it's a system if you last for an
hour then you've kind of done it okay
but you can do milk like after whatever
you want you can do milk afterwards
whatever you want but that does it erase
it I mean yeah so it's it's whenever you
tap out oh [__] I would I would I would
dump it dunk it in milk entirely I'm not
Dan I I can't take the milk no can't do
it it's like Jay's like the guy on a
loan who's like no breaks his ankle how
many people would sign up for our
patreon if I get these guys too start
doing hot food challenges all right
okay we're gonna close this show on this
how about this if we if we get a
thousand patreon
let's get to a thousand and we'll do it
so we we're not a thousand more it's the
number we're all a thousands
and we'll be honest about it we'll be
honest about it we can get to a thousand
we get to a thousand I will take the hot
chip challenge on our patreon all right
here we go five bucks a month I'll join
you yeah I seriously will join you to
close things out Jeremiah's specialist
called daddy look at it on YouTube and
rate it give it a thumbs up you know if
you share it the shares are helpful the
comments sure I'm gonna do it uh later
today I'm gonna check it out
um all right here we go uh the gimpy
gimpy uh he bought him he's just you
know what this fool is yeah yeah how old
is he how old wait are we doing both
yeah 60 bucks Australian Daniel Emeline
hyphen Jones how old is how old you saw
him you saw this face he is the physical
embodiment of a burner account that's a
28 year old man what do you think
I think he's actually pretty young how
old I think I think it's 25 25 it's like
Mark barrage uh I'm gonna say
36 all right get your answers in
counties because
Daniel emelyn Jones is
49 years old oh my God he looks great he
was well preserved a horrible looking 20
something girl you don't go outside ever
yes but that [__] is ready he's
in the garden he's gardening in his
house gardening at night all right there
you go that's a show we love you town
he's thanks for uh listening to the show
go check out uh Jeremiah daddy is the
name of the Santa specials Daddy it's so
simple to remember and you will enjoy it
because he's one of our favorites and uh
oh [__] we got to get back to work peace
town
[Music]